[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 culture une émission pour
vous présenter les projets culturels
dans les yvelines
au programme aujourd'hui nymag c'est un
projet lancé l'année dernière par quatre
professionnels du spectacle ils ont
réuni une dizaine d'enfants pour monter
une comédie musicale originale à
versailles nous sommes allés assister à
leur répétition confiné à versailles
chronique improbable d'un royal
explorateurs une bande dessinée qui fait
écho à l'époque actuelle
elle présente louis confiné au château
puis des confiné un album humoristique à
découvrir dans cette émission
et puis le centre des monuments
nationaux en partenariat avec le château
de maisons présentent l'exposition dans
le studio des frères s'héberger une
installation pour découvrir les
portraits de célébrités réalisé par les
deux photographes et je vous en parlais
en titre nymag gamins à l'envers c'est
un projet lancé l'année dernière par
quatre professionnels du spectacle ils
ont réuni une dizaine d'enfants pour
monter une comédie musicale originale à
versailles un projet en préparation à la
maison de quartier vauban nous sommes
allés assister à leurs répétitions avec
baptiste quart
[Musique]
à chacun son étoile c'est le nom de la
comédie musicale de la troupe nymag un
spectacle d'une heure trente monté avec
des enfants du territoire
un mélange de chants théâtre et mise en
scène le but faire rêver les enfants
c'est une envie commune une équipe de
quatre personnes de pouvoir faire
partager notre expérience de la scène du
spectacle à une bande d'enfants
objectif faire découvrir aux chanteurs
en herbe l'avis de professionnels du
spectacle les emmener en studio et donc
ils ont fait leur premier single ont
fait leur premier clip nabatéens vais
donc faire la première interview donc
c'est génial
la troupe est composée de quatre
professionnels du spectacle
auteur compositeur metteur en scène ou
encore coachs vocaux
ils sont là pour guider les enfants
pendant les répétitions
moi je suis là pour leur donner des
petites clés de temps en temps quand je
sens que c'est recevable pour eux mais
je vais pas très loin parce que je veux
simplement qu'ils soient bien ce sont
des enfants je vais pas leur mettre de
pression ou leur donner des outils
techniques trop pointu parce que j'ai
envie qu'ils s'amusent en fait
et parmi les enfants chacun a sa chanson
préférée
j'aime beaucoup ma chanson des l'étoile
des mers
[Musique]
là
j'aime beaucoup le final c'est ma
chanson c'est quand il ya tout le monde
sur scène et qu'on salue tous à la fin
et je trouve séquencé collectif quand on
est tous là c'est les meilleurs
mouvements
faux
oh
l'histoire luna est une petite fille qui
vient d'emménager dans un nouveau
quartier elle fait appel à son étoile
symphonia
à deux elles partent dans un monde
imaginaire à la découverte de
personnages loufoques et attendrissant
un ours une étoile de mer ou encore un
fantôme c'est un peu le plus gentil
fantôme
il est détesté par tout les autres
fantômes et puis va se faire les amis du
coup avec symphonia et luna 7 enfants
participer à l'expérience nymag un
projet qui leur a permis de s'affirmer
avant j'arrivais pas du tout à chanter
devant les gens s'étaient même pas
devant mes parents alors que là je
m'apprête à faire un spectacle devant
tous les parents de toute la comédie
musicale et j'ai vraiment pris confiance
en moi une représentation de la comédie
musicale aura lieu le 25 septembre à
versailles les 7 et 9 juillet prochain
vous pourrez venir écouter la parole des
habitants de sky
la compagnie du théâtre 7 septembre
basée à magny les hameaux travaille sur
ce projet j'habite hashtags 50 ans ni
vide depuis deux ans et un partenariat
avec le musée de la ville un spectacle
d'une heure quinze mettons scène des
témoignages des habitants de sky sur la
vie à saint quentin en yvelines
des récits récolté au préalable lors de
rencontres sur le territoire deux
comédiens et 5 saint quentinois a choisi
représenteront lé 12 communes de
l'agglomération ils relèveront à les
témoignages vraiment la grande majorité
des textes qui vont être dix sont des
textes qui ont été écrits par les
habitants s'étaient témoignages que j'ai
recueillis qui sont donc l'habitant par
aura sa ville comment il y vit qu'est ce
qui lie rêve
pourquoi il a choisi d'habiter là tout
simplement toutes ces questions et donc
l'idée aussi de parler des douze
communes de saint quentin en yvelines
et qu'est ce que c'est cette communauté
d'agglomération qui porte le nom de
saint quentin en yvelines et saint
quentin en yvelines il plein de gens
nous disent mais c'est où ça n'existe
pas et voilà donc c'est un petit peu
parlé tous à rassembler un petit peu le
ses douze communes autour donc de saint
quentin en yvelines
donc comment on y habite voilà tout
simplement deux représentations à venir
le 7 juillet à 20h30 au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
et le 9 juillet toujours à 20h30 au
scarabée salle de spectacle la verrière
l'accès à l'événement est gratuit pour
un début d'été culturel le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines présente les
escapades six spectacles en plein air à
plusieurs endroits de l'agglomération
jusqu'au 11 juillet au programme théâtre
musique cirque ou encore danser
l'événement continuera par la suite du
10 au 19 septembre plus d'informations
sur le site internet de la scène
nationale
confiné à versailles c'est le nom d'une
bd humoristique dessiné par une
illustratrice versaillaise pendant le
premier confinement l'histoire est celle
d'un petit louis et ce n'est pas louis
xiv ni louis saez mais c'est bien un
petit garçon intemporel il habite au
château de versailles il vit les
contraintes d'aujourd'hui mais dans un
autre siècle des petits épisodes qui
rappelle à l'humour avec humour ce que
l'on vit depuis plus d'un an
l'interview de l'auteur recueillis par
juliette prigent c'est un petit peu un
voyage dans le temps parce que c'est
s'aider des contraintes qui nous sont
donnés aujourd'hui avec les mots
d'aujourd'hui mais transposé dans un
siècle différents d'où par exemple s'il
ya distanciation sur sociale dans les
autobus va comme il se déplacer à cheval
il ya un cavalier sur deux dans les
rangs créé par exemple voilà c'est cette
genre de de décalage qui est un petit
peu petit peu drôle j'ai posé des
questions à mes à mes lecteurs je leur
ai dit si vous étiez ont fermé tout seul
dans le château de versailles
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce qu'il vous
plairait et en fait et en fait j'ai eu
des réponses donc sur instagram il ya ba
moi si j'étais tout seul
j'aimerais avoir la galerie des glaces
pour moi tout seul je ferai une grosse
fête
ou alors ce serait des frais des
glissades et ses ébats et passe à ce qui
est arrivé des counties lui un moment là
je l'envoie faire des glissades dans la
galerie des glaces
j'ai justement fait attention à remettre
un tout petit peu le contexte à chaque
fois avec des dates précises et qu'on
peut retrouver ou des références à des
des allocutions présidentielles
ministériel dé des conflits sur
l'intérêt du mas de tels traitements
voilà à chaque fois c'est vraiment
l'histoire de l'année 2020 transposé
dans un monde un peu virtuel à
versailles
la bande dessinée est disponible en
librairie et sur le site de l'auteur qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran et la suite
des aventures de louis à découvrir sur
le site également
c'est l'événement culturel phare de cet
été partir en livre revient pour une
nouvelle édition à saint quentin en
yvelines pendant un mois cette fête du
livre est organisé par le réseau des
médiathèques de l'agglomération sediag à
ton goût bonsoir bonsoir vous allez nous
expliquer cet événement oui du 30 juin
au 29 juillet partir en livre revient
pour une septième édition l'événement
s'inscrit dans un dispositif national
dont le principe est de sortir des
médiathèques et de proposer des
animations autour du livre et de la
lecture
la lecture peut paraître quelque peu
rébarbative rimbaud lecture et et quand
même associé à l'école donc là c'est les
vacances
il n'y a pas que la lecture sérieuse
apprentissage et fit la lecture ludique
l'idée c'est de proposer un maximum
d'activités autour de de la créativité
imagination
quel sera donc le programme à 50 ans
neeve insee lien alors il y aura de
nombreuses activités et des ateliers
tout au long du mois à villepreux magny
les hameaux guyancourt maurepas ou
encore plaisir
activités manuelles dessin manga contes
expositions exposition il en aura pour
tous les goûts avec un temps fort à la
commanderie à elancourt les vendredi 9
et samedi 10 juillet de 10 heures à 18
heures le réseau des médiathèques en
partenariat avec la commanderie investi
tout où les tous les espaces de la
commanderie avec une proposition de
village littéraire avec un espace
lecture des expositions des concerts des
lectures des jeux des ateliers manuels
d'illustration autres dates samedi 17
juillet à la médiathèque jacques-prévert
et aux quartiers du village des
clayes-sous-bois en après-midi sous le
signe de la magie avec des quizz pour
tester vos connaissances sur les mondes
fantastiques les histoires qui enchante
ou encore la création d'un carnet de
voyage et à maurepas tous les jeudis du
mois
des lectures et des comptes en plein air
seront proposées à l'air de jeu de
cartes le pirate est donc la caisse
sanitaires on va quand même permis de
faire évoluer les pratiques puisqu'il y
aura aussi une programmation en ligne
oui sur le portail des immédiate est de
saint quentin en yvelines
vous pourrez retrouver de nombreux
contenus présentation du compteur
ludovic souliman
vous pouvez retrouver aussi une
proposition d'activités autour de la
comptine de la souris verte qu'on peut
chambouler
donc c'est une petite activité
d'écriture pouvait aussi trouver une
sélection de livres de lecture autour de
la métamorphose
pour plus d'information vous pouvez
retrouver le programme en intégralité en
livre de partir en livre également sur
le portail en ligne des médiatiques
merci ses blagues à tsongo d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir le journaliste pour tv
78è les photos de gens et albert ces
bergers et grands photographes français
du 20e siècle sont mises à l'honneur au
château de maisons jusqu'au 11 octobre
l'exposition dans le studio des frères
ces bergers et révèle une sélection de
portraits de personnalités de la seconde
guerre mondiale jusqu'aux trente
glorieuses elles ont été conservés par
le centre des monuments nationaux le
reportage de juliette prigent grigori
canale et c'est agathe son goût roger
points clés christian dior ou en
joséphine baker lors d'un concours
d'élégance automobile les photos des
frères ces bergers sont présentés dans
l'exposition dans le studio des frères
s'héberger au château de maisons
laffitte des années 1940 à 1977
une centaine d'oeuvres sont exposées des
tirages photos moderne mais aussi des
objets comme des appareils photo des
frères ses berges et des revues et des
documents d'archivés prêtée par la
bibliothèque nationale de france
objectif raconter l'histoire d'une
dynastie familiale de photographe jean
et albert sont deux frères dont le père
et les oncles étaient également
photographe
donc c'est une histoire familiale que
l'on raconte dans cette exposition
histoire d'une dynastie de photographes
français avec une chronologie qui part
en gros du tout début du 19e siècle dans
la première photo de la famille
s'héberger c'est 1898 de jules et
jusqu'en 1977 dans la galerie des
célébrités on peut retrouver des
portraits d'edith piaf louis armstrong
ou encore jean cocteau
c'est vrai qu'ici on sent que les frères
ces bergers ont vraiment réussi à
capturer
à la fois une expression du poète
tourmenté et grands créateurs est aussi
l'homme dans son intimité domestique
voilà tout à fait séduisant dans cette
exposition se trouve également une
reconstitution d'un labo avec lumières
rouges épinglés au mur une petite
cinquantaine de photos présentant des
constructions d'autoroutes ou de stade
on y trouve aussi des témoignages de
tous les petits métiers de paris de
l'après-guerre qui ont disparu
progressivement donc artisans de paris
on y trouve aussi des photos de vacances
voilà donc ça permettait de montrer plus
généralement la diversité de leur
travail photographique pour le château
de maisons laffitte qui date du xviie
siècle
cette exposition permet de diversifier
la programmation culturelle
rendez-vous au sous-sol du château pour
la découvrir jusqu'au 11 octobre
et parmi les autres expositions jusqu'au
12 septembre vous pourrez découvrir
anna diffuse dans l'atelier une
exposition présentée au palais du roi de
rome musée d'art et d'histoire de
rambouillet une installation une
installation dédiée donc annadif deux
artistes rambo liten peintures dessins
et gravures une trentaine d'oeuvres
seront exposés
objectif plonger dans l'atelier de
l'artiste et puis la dix septième
édition de la nuit européenne des musées
ça se passe ce week-end samedi 3 juillet
rendez-vous dans les établissements
culturels des yvelines les lieux
participants vous ouvrent leurs portes
en nocturne pour l'occasion elle c'est
le cas par exemple du musée rend boli
train du musée de la toile de jouy est
de la maison natale claude debussy ou
encore du musée du jouet est la plus
part aux accueille gratuitement jusqu'à
minuit plus d'informations sur le site
qui s'affiche
c'est la fin de ce numéro du 7-8
sculpture merci à tous de nous avoir
suivi mardi prochain on se retrouve pour
une émission spéciale 30 ans du parc
france miniature très bonne soirée à
tous sur tv 78
[Musique]